how much it is when an operation like
this has taken place the white house is
aware of it a month two months three
months six months a year prior to it
happening like is this something that
might knew about three six months ago or
could is it last minute hey guys here's
where we are we found them let's make
the phone call take them out boom yeah
so generally speaking you know there's
kind of a pulse or tabs on guys in
certain areas when something like this
happens it's generally
to a degree with which there's very very
credible and corroborated through
multiple sources viable intelligence
that this guy is right here and now we
can go find him which is why you know
this is a big deal is that to to
pinpoint a guy and actually be accurate
as to his exact location going and
finding him even though we didn't kill
him he blew himself up the fact is the
result is the same is that that's a big
deal intelligence uh
wise you know as far as a victory so we
knew about it
for sure now
he's been on the radar is what you're
saying yeah but the opportunity uh
arises
but but what what's not said and what's
very possible i don't have any intimate
knowledge of it how many times did we
think he was somewhere tried to go and
nothing happened who knows it could have
been a dozen
you know so um
that's the the tricky part with this
like to your question
you know the the different directors and
and
you know people in different places of
of
of a high value in our government that
know okay this guy's in this region this
guy's in that region this outfit's
operating here they have about this many
troops
you know you have a good idea of you
know i'm gonna ask a crazy question and
i just want you to be thinking about it
both of you guys say tyler you think
about a c see how you process this so
you know sometimes somebody all of a
sudden has a bad rep for something they
did and they hire a publicist and the
publicist comes and tries to rebrand the
person right like a-rod rebranded
himself very well until the jlo
situation it kind of went back to
what it was i think a little bit right
he took a little bit of a step back but
when aaron came back out a-rod was
this guy listen i did it
here's what i did this is what it is
he's definitely transforming and then he
was on you know a shark tank you're
seeing him everywhere so you're like
this guy's incredible on tv great
communicator great all this stuff then
some people were up so what happened
with j.lo no one knows the real story
what happened there the jlo fans came
out and didn't like him but a-rod
recreated his persona would you guys
both agree who else would you put in
that category that recreated their
persona at that level i think
musicians do it rappers do it kardashian
did it
stars do it all the time right and
especially when you're getting older you
got to do it even more because if you
don't you're no longer 22 you're now 53
you don't look like you did at 22. you
got to kind of mix it up right
i wonder if there's meetings where
you're sitting there saying
look let's face it man and by the way
this i'm talking any president look
you're
you know score right now your polls
you're really good you're rating sucks
right now you ain't looking good you're
talking about buying nothing i'm not
buying them midterms are coming up we
got to kind of fix some things up so
listen five step plan here's what we're
going to do no longer we're going to
talk about cover we're going to talk
about cancer number two we need a strong
position from urine to go take out
somebody from isis let's call this
number three we need to do do you think
those types of conversations happen they
have to okay i agree i mean
no doubt
and i wonder if there's like a
30-point marker of things to do to
recreate your reputation
in these 30 markers okay which one of
these we want to do let's take this this
this this this you've had a publicist
before right sure know your relationship
it's their job to make you look better
to recreate you give you better talking
points all right listen you're gonna get
off the cover thing you're gonna start
focusing on cancer buddy you just
botched afghanistan let's kill some
mofos in syria this is
i think this is
you know pr 101 like get your ratings
back up and i think i needed that and
and to your point pat i think it's
important and i want to get mike's
thoughts on this as well notice it was a
raid and they didn't send in a drone
they didn't send in a reaper because
what happened last time we did that we
killed the aid worker and what seven
children yeah drone pat tillman i mean
so so where does that come from the is
it situational where they decide to raid
or yeah it is i mean so much of it is
going to be driven by kind of the the
actionable intelligence on what's on
target now
speaking from personal experience you
know we we did operations where our
intelligence was spot on and there were
times where we did uh operations where
the intelligence was woefully inaccurate
you know and that's kind of the the dice
roll that you take with any of these
things is that it's always
from a collateral damage standpoint i
would say generally speaking not always
it's it's a better mechanism to to send
human beings there to execute a mission
because they're they're thinking on
target now it doesn't mean that it can't
go wrong where
civilians are using uh or being used as
shields or kids get blown up or things
of that nature but you at least have a
an interactive component on the ground
that can make decisions
uh whereas you know once once the
trigger is pulled on a on a drone
hellfire uh you know that's it so
um
you know when it comes to to things like
this it's
it's generally uh regarded as the better
decision for the big picture to to send
people now the the obvious drawback is
that what if some of our our guys get
lost
my my perception of especially how this
administration would would view that is
that uh that that's not a huge
consideration on their part it's a
hundred percent how is it going to make
us look good or
uh you know what what is the pr going to
be based on on something like this
happening so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you